new dancing with the stars season 25
casting news get ready to be majorly
inspired hi everybody jason benetti
along with you and alongside is victoria
arlen paralympic swimming gold medalist
very excited to be here with you jason a
source tells et that espn tv personality
victoria arlen is joining the cast
she'll be paired with dancing pro val
schmerkovsky and he's beyond excited
about the decision
the source adds quote he's completely
re-energized and is feeling really
optimistic about this season
22 year old victoria's road to the
ballroom is an inspiring one
at the age of 11 she developed two
incredibly rare conditions that left her
paralyzed
i had to watch helplessly
as my ability
to walk
talk
and move
and think
were deteriorating in front of my eyes
doctors pretty much gave up hope but
after almost four years victoria began
the nearly impossible fight back to life
learning to speak eat and move all over
again
i learned how to swim without the use of
my legs and two and a half years later i
found myself swimming in the london
paralympic games
and she went on to win gold
[Music]
today you'd never know there was a time
victoria couldn't walk
she's not just standing strong she's
dancing too
now abc won't comment on this casting
news but will reveal the full cast next
week
[Music]